AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT GAME, HE'S
GOT A WAY.
THE NEW YORK SENATE JUST
PASSED A BILL TO NAME A ROAD IN
LONG ISLAND AFTER DAD ROCK
LEGEND AND TERRIBLE DRIVER BILLY
JOEL.
SO NOW WHEN HE WRECKS HIS CAR HE
CAN CALL 911 AND SAY, WHERE DO
YOU THINK I AM? I AM ON ME
STREET.
NO, NOT ELTON JOHN PARKWAY.
BILLY JOEL (BLEEP)ING BOULEVARD.
COMEDIANS I WANT YOU TO GIVE
HE, GIVE ME THE NAMES OF SOME
BUSINESSES ON BILLY JOEL
BOULEVARD, 60-SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK, BEGIN.
>> JUST THE WAY YOU ARE PLASTIC
SURGERY.
>> Chris: POINTS.
BARON.
>> WE DIDN'T START THE FIRE
ROASTED PIZZA.
>> Chris: POINTS. PROOPS.
>> BEVMO.
>> Chris: POINTS.
MATT BRAUNGER.
>> UPTOWN SQUIRREL, URBAN PET
STORE.
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT.
POINTS.
GREG.
>> ANOTHER BEVMO.
>> Chris: POINTS.
>> ONLY THE GOOD DIE YOUNG
MORTUARY.
>> Chris: POINTS.
GREG.
>> COMBO BEVMO-PIZZA HUT.
>> Chris: POINTS.
YEAH.
GREG.
>> SELL US A THONG, YOU'RE THE
PANTY MAN.
>> Chris: POINTS.
THAT IS REALLY GOOD.
GOD DAMNIT.
BARON.
>> OH, I LIKE YOU JUST THE WAY
YOU SPARR GYM.